by the side of a Motorway in a remote
corner of Canada the moment four days of
Terror came to a dramatic end
side the white truck is Miles Sanderson
suspected of involvement in one of
Canada's worst ever mass murders hours
later he died while in police custody
the search for Clues and for a motive
had centered on this indigenous
community at James Smith Queen Nation
where most of the ten murders took place
this evening our province is breathing a
collective sigh of relief as miles
Sanderson is no longer at Large
I can confirm that he is no longer a
threat and there is no risk to the
public related to this investigation
before this week few on this Reserve
overlooked their doors let alone
imagined that this horror could be
visited upon them now they're counting
they're dead
ten people stabbed to death aged between
23 and 78 including Gloria Burns a drug
addiction counselor and Lana head a 49
year old mother of two
sanderson's brother Damien also a
suspect in the murders had been found
dead in a field with stab wounds
over 160 officers hunted for 32 year old
miles Sanderson who went into medical
distress after his arrest
this community is paying respect to
those who were killed the danger is now
over but the sense of loss Will endure
and with the death of the Sanderson
Brothers any chance of answers is gone
to Martha Kellner Sky News